Jeff's with us in Phoenix hey Jeff how
are you I'm well Dave thank you very
time today sir sure how can I help well
I have a question about 401k for
retirement I saw a documentary on PBS
and it kind of showed some pretty
compelling evidence that investing for
retirement 401ks because of all the fees
that are associated with it that over
like 50 years it can I rode those fees
can I rode like 2/3 of your original
investment and they strongly advised the
advantages of being in something called
a market index fund versus mutual fund
so I guess my question is twofold
exactly what is a market index fund and
what's your opinion on it which one I
should be in for retirement okay a
market and an index is anything that
models an index fund is anything that
models a one of the particular indexes a
good best way to do is give you an
example the S&P 500 is an index the Dow
Jones Industrial Average that quotes
what stock market's done today on the
news is an index
the best with the best example is the
S&P 500 and what that is is Standard &
Poor as a company SP that rates does all
kinds of ratings and research on the
stock market and they have rated the top
500 companies in size on the New York
Stock Exchange which are the largest
companies in other words the pub the
largest publicly traded companies in
America so those 500 companies what
their stock does really does represent
in a very real way what the stock market
is doing
that's an index fund okay you could get
a index fund that is trying to measure
or mirror some of the international
markets or some of the small cap stocks
like on the Chicago exchange but the
most commonly known one that they would
be referring to in that would be
something like an S&P 500 now so if that
if that fact that those 500 stocks are
the index if you want to index to them
rather they're the measuring stick what
we're trying to do if we're creating an
S&P 500 index fund is we're trying to
create a fund that mirrors what those
stocks do
as a group it may or may not hold all
500 of them but they're doing their very
very best to do exactly what that index
does with that mutual fund okay so an SP
500 fund is really going to give you
pretty close to the exact rate of return
that the stock market gives you not any
better not any worse as a matter of fact
it's considered the baseline when you
measure against it to see if another
type of mutual fund is outperforming the
market you see what I'm saying that's
considered the 1.0 on a beta meaning
it's the baseline and if your fund if
you're graphing it if you're the line on
your funds growth is above the SP then
you outperform the market its below the
SP it's underperformed the market okay a
large number of mutual funds
underperform the market but there are
plenty of them that over perform that
outperform the market and so the problem
with the PBS special is this the number
one reason people retire with no money
is not because of rate of return and
it's not because of the fees it's
because they don't put any freaking
money in retirement that and we've got
tons of research that shows that and all
of these guys who start ripping on fees
or worrying about the 401 K structure
are you know from a liberal political
perspective try to figure out what's
wrong with America today and the
capitalism is somehow bad or something
and they've got that as their
undercurrent in a lot of these things
you're never allowed to charge a fee for
anything in their minds and it is the
undercurrent and it is PBS so we know
that's there but aside from that the
truth of the matter is that the research
indicates that getting people to invest
is the primary thing you do first the
second thing you do if they want to win
is the rate of return that they make on
their money the last thing that's an
indicator of whether they end up with
money is fees well I listened to your
show on it I mean it tells me I need to
be in those ammmm I work
401k with a match you show tells me
that's where I need to be you know and
I've heard you mentioned there's four
different kinds of mutual fund them all
you know related to risk and route and
return so I guess I'm asking so and
looking so last my the question is do I
think it's okay let me finish the one
last thing there if the main reason
people don't have money in retirement is
because they don't put any money in how
do you solve that you make it easy to
invest for retirement payroll deduction
is the easiest way if we're talking
about philosophy to get people to do
anything that's why the IRS gets away
with taking as much of our money as it
takes and we act like it's okay because
if you had an IRS guy standing at the
front door and you had to hand him cash
as you walked out everyday out of their
money you know there be there be a
dadgum revolution with what we pay in
taxes but we're all dumbed down by the
payroll deduction the 401 K allows that
same automatic way to do that so it so
I'm a fan of the 401 K philosophically
for that reason
now do I put money in my 401 K yeah I
put money in my personal 401 K is it the
only thing I do to build wealth no it's
not the only thing but it does keep the
government's hands off the taxes keep
off the money for taxes and if it's a
Roth IRA or Roth 401 K it's growing
tax-free and yes I recommend four types
of growth stock mutual funds none of
those were index funds by the way growth
growth and income aggressive growth and
international now in some 401 KS the
selection of funds that you're looking
at is so bad that that your growth fund
category could be filled with the sp500
your aggressive growth could be filled
with a Russell index which is the
aggressive growth index fund if there's
an index fund in there that's fine I'm
not against that but look at your mutual
funds inside your that you have the
opportunity to select and in every
mutual fund perspective there's that S&P
trendline baseline and then the trend
line of the growth on your particular
fund and you can see if the funds you're
looking at as a track record of
underperforming the market if it does
don't use it use an index fund
you know but yes these are all mutual
funds managed so all mutual funds have
those different levels of fees know
whether there's no load funds and
there's loaded funds all mutual funds
have some fees a no load fund means no
Commission that's what that means but it
has a maintenance fee and the
maintenance fee comes out every single
year the Commission comes out only at
the beginning so what you're looking at
is not if they have fees you're looking
at the what's called the expense ratio
when you look at the prospectus you can
look at that and you want to look at it
averaging over ten years what's the
average annual expense from all the fees
they're lumped into that one ratio in
your perspectives and it's federal law
it has to be in there okay and you're
looking at that here's why you look at
that let me give you an example this is
a great call by the way thank you for
asking these questions because it's real
helpful to teach everybody this on a no
load fund there's no Commission but they
charge an annual maintenance fee now if
they charge an annual maintenance fee
that's two percent and they do that over
ten years then their average is going to
be two percent we're a loaded mutual
fund with a commission might have a 5
and 3/4 percent most of them do
Commission on the front end when you buy
it and then any maintenance fee might be
0.5 or 0.6 and when you run that math
out it's going to be cheaper than a 2%
annual maintenance fee with no
Commission over a 10-year period of time
so your expense ratio can be cheaper
with a loaded fund your total expenses
you're paying over a 10-year period of
time can be cheaper than a mutual than
ain't no load fund but it's not always
so so if you're real concerned about
expenses then you look at that expense
ratio and it's the it's the true up it's
how you compare apples and oranges
between a commissioned fund and a
non-commissioned fund does that make
sense yes and so you look at the average
through there but here's the thing
listen to this if your expenses are up
1% higher average over a 10-year period
of time but you make 4% more rate of
return you came out to do that
and do that that's why that's why return
is your primary measure of which you of
how you pick a fund that's your primary
measure the last thing I look at is
expenses and very seldom do I find
expenses being the deal-breaker and you
know that's the reality
that's not theory that's the reality
good question
you